[Music]  LeBron needs one more thing before he  hangs him up he's said it before and  he's saying it again he needs to be on  the floor with his son bronny and that  doesn't necessarily mean they need to be  repping the same uniform LeBron will  take what he can get and Lebron's  contract allows him to opt out and  become a free agent in 2024. right when  brawny is eligible to enter into the NBA  draft at the end of the day LeBron just  really wants to have the Ken Griffey  Senior and Junior experience so the  question is will LeBron and brawny end  up together or against each other but  more importantly what do you guys think  about brawny in the NBA in general